des corona test fiasko muss
aufgearbeitet werden die bürger test
sind ja ab ersten juli eigentlich immer
kosten bis zum ersten juni immer
kostenlos gewesen jetzt werden sie aber
kostenpflichtig außerdem ausnahmefall
der grund gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sagte im zdf dass man sich
die tests nicht mehr leisten könne laut
lauterbach lagen die ausgaben teilweise
bei einer milliarde pro monat ich möchte
die leute gar nicht darüber debattieren
ob im test jetzt sinnvoll sind oder
waren
wie es weitergehen sollte mir geht es um
das mangelnde unternehmertum der politik
die milliarde pro monat kommt auch
zusammen weil missbrauch mit unserem
steuergeld betrieben wurde jeder konnte
ein testcenter gründen es war nicht nur
ärzte oder apotheker geführt hat jeder
ein testzentrum aufgemacht und die
anzahl der angeblich durchgeführten
tests konnten am anfang per strichliste
notiert werden das hat uns ja auch ein
apotheker vor wenigen tagen erzählt
ermittler gehen von einem schaden durch
erfundene test von mehr als einer
milliarde euro aus
[Musik]